Hello and welcome to yet another
video about diffusion models!
Every time Ms. Coffee Bean thinks she is done
with covering diffusion models, something
new appears on the diffusion model market,
something so awesome, she just cannot ignore.
MetaAI researchers have developed
a diffusion model that can produce
moving pictures, so video from text descriptions!
And while we were making this video,
Google Brain published Imagen Video, which
is another diffusion model that can produce
video. So we quickly included
that topic into this video too.
The pace at which diffusion models can
generate more and more of the visual world,
is mindblowing. Not to mention that they
also conquer the audio, and protein realm.
But let’s not get distracted
by other awesome modalities,
because here we go! Today we will explain
Make-A-Video and Imagen Video, two diffusion
models which tame the time dimension, to create
not just pictures, but movies, moving pictures!
But before we dive in, let’s thank Encord,
the active learning platform for computer
vision, who is the sponsor of this video!
Data is one of the most important parts of
creating innovative computer vision models.
The Encord platform has been
designed to make the creation
of training data and testing of ML
models quicker than it’s ever been.
Encord does this in two ways. Firstly, it
makes it easier to manage, annotate and
evaluate training data through collaborative
annotation tools and automation features.
Secondly, Encord offers access to
its QA workflows, APIs and SDK so
you can create your own active learning
pipelines, speeding up model development.
And by using Encord, you don’t need to
waste time building your own tools, letting
you focus on getting the right data into your
models. Click the link to try Encord for free.
Great, now back to video diffusion
models. To help wrap our heads around
this incredibly fast progress
in the diffusion models realm,
let’s make a timeline with some
of the most important milestones.
Diffusion models could beat
GANs on image synthesis and
draw photorealistic faces, starting May 2021.
Already December 2021, GLIDE from
OpenAI was a diffusion model that
could now generate images from text prompts.
In April 2022, OpenAI announced the
follow-up of GLIDE, which is DALL-E 2.
Then the options simply exploded:
there was Imagen from Google in May,
then Parti, also from Google in June,
Midjourney entered the open beta in July.
And these models are just to name
a few, sorry to everyone left out.
And of course, there was Stable Diffusion that
made a huge splash since it is lightweight and
freely available, so it can be used by anyone,
unlike all of the other diffusion models.
We should note that “coincidentally”,
the day that GLIDE was released,
was also the day that the research paper
which stands at the basis of Stable Diffusion,
so latent diffusion models,
was published on ArXiv.
Okay, so, this timeline is just so we can better
imagine how crowded the idea
space of diffusion models is.
Now we can sit back and relax from the diffusion
model hype, right? No, of course we can’t!
We just got used to models creating images
from text, but now we quickly move onto the
space of videos created from just a text
description! Video diffusion models have
already been a thing since April 2022 with very
short, GIF-like animations of still images.
The big splash in video diffusion was caused
by MetaAI that has shown through a paper,
they haven’t released the model (yet?)… So
MetaAI showcases Make-A-Video, a diffusion
model generating impressive videos from text
descriptions on the 29th of September 2022.
Then only a few days later, October the 5th,
Google Research announces its own artillery of
video diffusion models with Imagen Video, a
direct competitor to MetaAI’s Make-A-Video,
producing short videos from text with a realism
we have not yet seen before, and with Phenaki,
capable of generating longer videos of
about 2 minutes [not a diffusion model].
The videos of Phenaki are kind of creepy
and not that realistic, but they are long!
So today, we are diving in into video diffusion
models and explain how they work and in which
way Make-a-Video from MetaAI and Imagen Video
from Google differ and what they have in common.
If you are not yet familiar with how
diffusion models generate images,
then do check out our previous videos on
this first. It is important to understand
the underlying image mechanisms if we
are to comprehend video diffusion models,
because you can think of images
being videos with a single frame.
For this explanation, we will assume that we
already know what an image diffusion model is.
We start our explanations of text-to-video
generators by explaining Make-A-Video from
Meta AI. We choose this one for the
start, because it is a special kind
of video diffusion model: it is a natural
enhancement of text-to-image generation,
because it uses text-to-image diffusion models
to build them in as-are for video diffusion.
And since we assume we are already
familiarized with image diffusion models,
Make-A-Video is a great place to start.
How to generate a short video with
diffusion models? The core idea of
Make-A-Video is to take a text-to-image
diffusion model that already knows how the
visual world looks like and what
its correspondence with text is.
Then, it extends the text-to-image model
with video processing schnick-schnack and
uses video data (unlabeled, so unpaired)
to learn realistic motion. In this way,
one does not need paired text-video data, which
makes the training data requirements so much
better. This is a way to generate short,
low resolution and low framerate models.
Then additional models can take care of
interpolating between frames to increase
the frame rate, then super-resolution
models can take care of transforming
frames into high resolution.
Let’s take it step by step.
First, we have the text-to-image diffusion model,
which shares the core components with DALL-E 2.
The text-to-image diffusion model takes in noise
and step by step, it generates images of 64x64
resolution. It considers the text information in
the following way: The CLIP text encoder embeds
the text into a multimodal visual-language
space. A so-called “prior” network translates
the text vector into the corresponding
image vector in the CLIP embedding space.
Because we remember that CLIP was
trained to embed images and their
captions into vectors close to each other. Then
the diffusion model takes in this image vector,
which is a visual equivalent of the
text prompt and uses it to gradually
generate a faithful image to the text prompt.
Ok, so this was the DALL-E 2 recap in a nutshell.
This text-to-image diffusion model,
trained on paired text-image data
(so usually images and their captions)
can now generate pictures from text.
A first super-resolution
network enhances the image
to 256x256 resolution and a second one
to 768x768 pixels. Much like DALL-E 2.
Now we are ready for the video-specific
technical schnick-schnack. The U-Net
producing clearer and clearer images at each
diffusion step so far, had two-dimensional
convolution and attention layers to ensure
coherence in the 2d structure of the image.
Now for video, the U-Net needs to be extended
into the temporal dimension to ensure temporal
coherence. For the convolution layers, the authors
could have used 3D convolutions, but that would
have been computationally expensive, so instead
they do the image-like 2D convolution as before,
and add a 1D convolution following it, to
combine the frames, so the temporal dimension.
This means, the network can keep all its trained
image convolution weights and only the 1D,
temporal convolution layers need
to be trained from scratch. Cool.
To use the authors words, at initialization,
because the 1D convolutions connecting the
temporal dimension are random, the network
will generate different images at each frame,
each describing the text, but
lacking temporal coherence.
For the attention layers, the authors
do a similar thing to the convolution,
especially since 3D attention would have been even
more expensive than 3D convolutions. Following
each spatial attention layer, which is already
there from the pretrained text-to-image U-Net,
they stack an attention layer after the spatial
attention, to combine the temporal dimension.
Now, you can imagine why this approach only
generated short videos: as the videos grow longer,
so does the number of frames one needs to
generate, so the attention window grows too,
so computation scales quadratically.
I wonder if windowed attention like
in the Swin Transformer would help
diminish the compute issues here.
To make the generated videos have
a higher frame rate, the authors
use a frame interpolation network trained on
general video data to predict masked frames.
So how is this whole thing trained? Many things
are trained independently. The authors train the
“prior” network and the super-resolution
networks on images alone. They train the
text-to-image diffusion model on paired
text-image data, no fine-tuning on videos!
Then the authors add the video-specific
convolution and attention layers and train
on unlabeled video data. All in all, this work
is a beast of a network that makes clever use
of existing models and of easily available
data: It is easier to find images and their
captions than visual descriptions of videos (not
subtitles!) on a large scale on the internet.
Let’s summarize Make-A-Video to later
compare it to Imagen Video. We have the
input text prompt and run it through an
encoder to transform it into a vector.
A prior network translates the CLIP text
vector into the corresponding CLIP image
vector. Then a Base diffusion model which was
first trained to generate images from text,
just like DALL-E 2, gets additional
convolution and attention layers onto
the temporal dimension to combine different
frames, so single images, into a video.
A temporal super-resolution network does
frame interpolation, so it increases the
temporal resolution by producing more
and more frames in between frames.
Then two spatial-super resolution models upscale
the individual frames to increase the
resolution of the video, frame by frame.
Now we know how Make-A-Video works. Now,
let’s look at Google’s approach: How does
Imagen Video generate videos with diffusion?
To put it this way, what would we need to change
in Make-A-Video to make Imagen Video? We would
need to change this cascade of diffusion models
to end up with a cascade of 7 models. First,
we would need to replace the text encoder
by a frozen T5-XXL text transformer,
which was trained on lots
and lots of text-only data.
Then, a little different is how the base video
diffusion model is trained. Architecturally, it
is also a U-Net enhanced with temporal attention
and temporal convolutions to bind the individual
images together which are part of the same video.
It is basically the training of this that differs.
The authors train it on images and videos
simultaneously, where they treat single
images as single frame videos. But this
means that for the video training data,
they do need aligned video and text description
(which means they use a Google-internal dataset
for this), while Make-A-Video got
away without aligned text-video data.
The story continues like for Imagen,
with a temporal supersampling network
that produces more frames. It is followed
by two spatial-super resolution models,
like with Make-A-Video. But then we have
two more temporal upsampling models to
produce more frames, then yet another
spatial supersampling. Done. This,
in a nutshell, is the raw difference
between Imagen Video and Make-A-Video.
And with classifier-free guidance,
which we covered in another video
and with some other little tricks, this
cascade of 7 models just seems to work,
which must be a great achievement for the
authors, since this is direct follow-up of
their previous work on diffusion models marking
the territory in video diffusion modelling.
In their previous work, they were proving
the concept that video diffusion models
are possible by producing 64-frames
of 128x128 at 24 frames per second.
Now Imagen can do 128 frames long
1280x768 HD videos, also at 24 FPS.
The multitude of ways to do and
to combine things in the diffusion
model space and the lack of insight
for why a thing works and in which
constellation it doesn’t, makes it so hard
to wrap Ms. Coffee Bean’s head around this.
Her hypothesis is that nobody knows
why diffusion models work and which
combination of tricks is the best and why
tricks do the trick in the first place.
If you are interested in even more video diffusion
models, do check out Phenaki, which is also a
video diffusion model published the same day
as Imagen Video from another group at Google,
capable of producing long video, where of course,
the realism suffers a bit at this kind of length.
Ms. Coffee Bean cannot wait
to see what kind of long and
realistic videos will come out of the
diffusion models of the next 3 months.
What do you think of this diffusion model
flurry? How are you going to use them in
your work and everyday life? We hope to read from
you in the comments. See you in the next video!
Okay, bye!